[موسيقى]
لو موت ما حدش هيتفين والله احسن من
النهار
الاب الذي اثنى عمره يعملوه لبناء مستقبلي
اولاده وبناته ليكافئوه باستخراج شهاده
وفاه له وهو على قيد الحياه والسبب هو
الطمع في الميراث
[موسيقى]
ايه اللي حصل لي
اذا ضحك فجاه كده اولاده كلموني وانا كنت
بروح عندهم قالوا لي ان ابوهم مات
حضرتك ما سالتهمش مات ازاي
جثمان حتى
لان هم كانوا طلعوا شويه وفاه احنا ما
نعرفش طلعه ازاي
يعني ولا ايه الولد
[موسيقى]
يعني هو اللي جنبي انا كنت اعرف ثلاثه
ايام عنده ما اعرفش
انت لما كنت مسافر مكنتش بتتواصل معهم
بعد كده اقول له يا ابن الغالي ومش عارف
اطلعها لك يوم الاثنين يا ابني
اي حاجه انت عايزها نعملها انما شهاده
وفاه خالص
وعيال يشاهدوا ان انا مش هاقول الولد ده
عمي وده مش ابويا يعتبر فؤاد جايب واحد من
الشارع شبه يعني
الطب الشرعي سهل جدا يثبت ان انت ابوهم
حولهم بقى الطب الشرعي
ما رحوش ثلاث مرات نروح نحضر ما بياخذوش
منه
لازم التحليل يكون الطرف الثاني لما الولد
قال ده مش ابويا اللي قاضي حولنا احنا
الاثنين
[موسيقى]
بعد 12 يوم 12 يوم
ثمان سنين انت ماشي معك شهاده وفاتتك معي
[موسيقى]